القصف متواصل كثيرا ما ذكر
عن يعني لم يعد هناك قدره استيعاب لدى
مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس لاستقبال الجرحه
لكن ضعنا في صوره كيف تتعاملون مع كل هذه
الاعداد ومع المجازر المرتكبه وعشرات
الشهداء والجرحى الذين يسقطون
يوميا حقيقه من صباح اليوم وصل الى مستشفى
ناصر اكثر من 120 اصابه منهم بعض الاصابات
التي اي واجهت صعوبه في الوصول الى مستشفى
ناصر وتلقي الخدمات بقيت تحت الردم لاكثر
من ع ساعات نيابه عن القصف المتتابع من
ساعات المساء منذ الامس اي وصل الينا اكثر
من 60 شهيد اخرهم خمسه شهداء وصلوا
بسيارتين اسعاف
كثير من حالات الشهداء يبدو عليها علامات
التاخر الوصول لمستشفى ذلك لصعوبه وصول
سيارات الاسعاف وطاقم الاسعاف الطبي الى
مناطق الاستهدافات مع انها مناطق قريبه من
مستشفى ناصر ومن مركز مدينه خانيونس جزء
كبير كان منهم من جنوب منطقه المستشفى
وغرب المستشفى اعداد متفاوته تحتوي العديد
من
اال حاليا قبل ساعه من الزمن كان في خمس
غرف عمليات ممتلئه وكان هناك حالات طبيه
تحتاج الى الدخول الى عمليات طارئه واجهنا
صعوبه حاليا نواجه صعوبه كبيره في قله او
محدوديه الطاقم الطبي الذي هو اصلا مجهد
منذ بدايه
الحرب ذلك بسبب الوضع الامني السيء الذي
قد تكون تسمعون يعني صوت الاشتباكات بشكل
واضح قريب من مستشفى ناص صر كطاقم طبي
منهك عدد قليل محدوديه
الامكانيات يوجد لدينا بعد توسعه غرفه
العنايه واستخدام غرف غير مؤهله مؤهله
لتكون غرف عنايه لكن لظروف الطارئه لدينا
اقل من 40 سرير عنايه في مستشفى ناصر جميع
الاسره العنايه ممتلئه لا يوجد اسره شاغره
حقيقه هذا يضيف مصاعب اخرى في استقبال
الحالات الحرجه او الحالات التي تخرج من
العمليات بحالات ايضا تحتاج الى متابعه
طبيه امتلاء
قسم الجراحه حقيقه
وقسم جراحه العظام جراحه لعدم توفر ايضا
قسم جراحه اعصاب او جراحه اطفال بالقدرات
المحدوده من الاطباء الموجودين نحاول ان
نستوعب اكبر عدد ممكن لكن في ظل الاعداد
الكبيره التي ترد الى مستشفى ناصر هذا
للامانه يعطي صعوبه كبيره للموقف نعم الذي
نعيش في مستشفى ناصر اعرف انه ليس من من
السهوله طرح هذا السؤال
لكن هل
هل بداتم
بالتعامل
مع الجرحه والمصابين بمبدا المفاضله
الان
للاسف لقد بدانا منذ من قبل هذه الفتره
بالعمل بمبدا
المفاضله بين الحالات الحرجه والاشد حروج
وخطرا
والاقل حتى في غرفه الانعاش يعني بدانا
بتطبيق هذا في داخل غرفه الانعاش اللي هي
تعتبر الغرفه الحمراء او الخط الاحمر عننا
كطاقم طبي في قسم الطوارئ نفاضل بين او
نسارع الوقت في محاوله
اي المحافظه على حياه المصابين او المرضى
الذين يصلون بالاضافه الى ضغط العدد الطبي
بان ان منطقه او محيط مستشفى ناصر محيط
ممتلئ بمدارس النزوح الذي يزيد ضغط الى
الحالات الطبيه حالات الا الازمه الصدريه
الاوبا المحليه هيباتايتس اي الاسهالات
المائيه التي تنتشر بصوره كبيره في
المنطقه ذلك يؤدي الى ضغط اضافي الى عدد
او بجانب عدد الاصابات الذي يتوارد بشكل
لا متناهي الى قسم الطوارئ في مستشفى ناصر
طيب بالنسبه لقسم الطوارئ
تحديدا كيف يستوعب هذا العدد من من
الجرحى وهو قسم يعني ليس كبيرا باعتبار ان
المستشفى حجمه لا يشبه باقي المستشفيات
الكبرى في في قطاع
غزه للاسف مستشفى ناصر حاليا يعتبر الاكبر
في قطاع غزه بعد اخراج مستشفى الشفاء
الطبي عن العمل اي اليه استيعاب الاعداد
الكبيره
قد ترونها عن طريق الفيديوهات المنتشره
كيف يتعامل الاطباء مع المرضى على بدون
اسره على الارض مباشره في الممرات الطبيه
هذه صوره للضغط الطبي الواضح او الاعداد
الكبيره الهائله التي تتوافد الى مستشفى
ناصر
حقيقه الوضع سيء ضغط كبير اعداد هائله
اصابات
كثيره تاخر في الوصول الى هذه الاصابات او
صعوبه احضارها الى مستشفى ناصر نشاهد
كثيره من الحالات الطبيه التي تاتي بوسائل
النقل المحليه صراحه الى المستشفى
اي نحاول ان نتعامل مع الحالات الحرجه فال
الحرجه اي الى وصولها لحاله الاستقرار ثم
يتم عمليه فرز هذه الحالات منهم جزء كبير
يدخل الى العنايه للاسف العنايه لا يوجد
فيها اسره شاغره نهائيا الجزء الضغط حاليا
على غرف العمليه خاصه كثيرا من الاصابات
التي تتوارد الينا اصابات لديها الاصابات
متعدده بالشظايا او البطو او التهشم خاصه
بالاطراف او الاصابات البليغه والنزيف
الداخلي تحتاج الى دخول طارئ الى عمليات
الجراحه محدوديه غرف الجراحه حاليا يضعنا
في ضغط اخر من جانب اخر اي بالاضافه الى
نحاول يعني قد نضطر احيانا الى التعامل مع
الحالات الحرجه الحالات التي تحتاج بالاصل
لعمليات جراحيه في غرفه الانعاش وهي غرفه
صغيره اصلا تحتوي فقط على اربعه اسره جهاز
تنفس صناعي واحد جهاز الترا ساوند تلفزيون
تصوير
واحد نضطر او نضطر للتعامل مع الحالات على
الارض بشكل مباشر او في الممرات يعني حفظا
لحياه الناس او نصارع الوقت لمحاوله
الانقاظ والحفاظ على حياه الناس دكتور
هيثم احمد الطبيب في قسم الطوارئ بمستشفى
ناصر من قن يونس شكرا جزيلا لك